okay welcome back everyone uh for the
afternoon session today we will again
have um two talks and
then a break and then another talk in
the panel so uh as we've done um
yesterday and this morning is that we'll
keep uh the questions that are the
substantive questions for the panel
afterwards that if you have
clarification questions
um please just raise your hand and uh
anna will call on you and for those of
you on zoom um i'll be tracking the chat
there if you want to uh
put in a question there and i'll try to
get that question in here with arnhem
okay i'm delighted to have you here anna
bhattacharya from the national
university of singapore the floor is
yours okay
uh thank you thank you to ben and
caroline for the organization and for
inviting me it's a pleasure and honor to
be here so i'll be speaking about a
property testing viewpoint on
learning and testing causal models
um
this is joint work with several people
who i'll mention during the course of
the talk now one thing to observe is
that my last name has two wise this will
be important
later on as you'll see
okay
um
yeah so here is a kind of one slide uh
summary of uh of what the talk is going
to be about
so algorithms and um
in for causality right so often they
rely on statistical tests so for example
causal discovery algorithms often use a
conditionally independent circle where
you're given three sets of variables
you're trying to check whether x and y
are conditionally independent given z uh
whenever you talk about equivalence
between two distributions underlying
that is an identity test
which checks the equality of two
distributions
so what we do in this talk is we kind of
look under the hood
and
obtain a more refined picture
of how the
oops
how the
the number of samples that we
that we use for these tests how they
affect the quality of the results okay
in particular we'll differentiate
between the number of samples we take
from observational versus interventional
distributions and we'll see that there's
kind of a richer landscape than i mean
than you get then if you just look at
i mean tests as an abstraction instead
of
more carefully at the number of samples
you draw from each of these
distributions
okay so with that being said uh that
yeah so the viewpoint through which i'll
talk about these finite sample
complexity results is through this lens
of distribution property testing so in
property testing we ask the following
question so you have access to some
distribution d
and there's a particular property p that
you want to check whether the
distribution possesses or not and the
question you ask is how many samples
from d do you need to draw in order to
distinguish between the two these two
cases that d satisfies a property versus
d is far from any distribution that
satisfies the property so let me just
quickly show you an example
like the kind of theorems i'm talking
about so this is drawn from a very nice
survey by claymore
on a survey on distribution testing i
think this is going to be turned into a
book soon
so so this
describes an algorithm which tests
identity
between
an unknown distribution d and a
reference distribution d star okay and
what it says is that if d star and b are
drawn from
distributions on a set of size n
then the
algorithm makes square root of n over
epsilon square many samples from the
unknown distribution
and it has the following two properties
that if d equals d star then with
probability at least two thirds
algorithm
if d is uh far from d star um
with this parameter epsilon then uh with
probably at least two thirds the
algorithm rejects okay
uh so
yeah right so you might wonder how
property testing contrasts to kind of
more classical questions and hypothesis
testing so i mean there are similarities
and differences i mean one main
difference is that here the focus is on
non-asymptotic analysis so we won't talk
about asymptotic normality
or i mean what happens when the number
of samples go to infinity but rather
on guarantees that you get with small
number of samples and with the
sample complexity is often sub-linear in
the domain size
whereas in uh for hypothesis testing
often the number of samples grows at
least linearly with the domain size okay
and um and also typically this is this
line of work has been pursued for
distributions over finite domains and
that is also the the context in which
we'll talk about our work uh there are
some extensions to continuous settings
but i won't describe that here okay
all right so let me first talk about so
i'll talk about two two different works
so the first work is joined with jaydev
acharya sarah badani sarvanan tandasamy
and zeetang son they're all at cornell
this is work is not published yet but i
mean you can ask me for it
so it will be public soon
okay so here we
ask a very very simple basic question i
mean so let me motivate with the
example which i'm sure is familiar to
all of you here um i mean cancer and
smoking so in 1950 there was this
landmark study by dolan hill who showed
that smoking and cancer are correlated
so smokers are more likely than
non-smokers to get cancer
and then
in 1957 based on this study and other
more comprehensive ones the british
medical research council
they
suggested that smoking causes lung
cancer and so people should stop smoking
to prevent
lung cancer
and then there came along um
ronald
fisher
founder of modern statistics a very
cranky dude and
a
chain smoker so he suggested that i mean
i'm rightly so that the data doesn't i
mean obvious i mean doesn't mean that
smoking causes cancer it could be that
cancer causes some kind of inflammation
and that makes people smoke to relieve
the pain or it could be that there's
some underlying genetic cause which
causes both
and as fisher would have said i mean the
only true way to know the direction of
causality is to perform interventional
experiments which is the focus of this
workshop and i mean it's very clear what
you do right so
so if you want to know whether x causes
y then if you do an intervention on x
then the distribution of y would be
affected but otherwise not similarly for
y not a y to x
and if u is causing hidden variables
causing both x and y then interventions
would not affect
either of the two okay
so the question we want to look at is
i mean how to realize this i mean this
i mean
the schema in practice right so in
practice if you
were to perform interventions you would
realize it by performing some randomized
control trial which has some finite
number of samples so the question is how
many samples really do you need to take
from the observational distribution and
the interventional distribution
so that
you can guarantee you you have a
guarantee about the success probability
okay so in particular
yeah here is an interesting question
that we can ask can we save on
interventional samples the samples we
draw from interventional distributions
if you take more than the necessary
needed necessary number of samples from
observational distribution okay is there
a trade-off and
and what is that trade what does that
tradeoff look like so we actually
solved this question in a very tight way
so here is the setup so i'll describe
the result a bit informally so suppose
you have two random variables x and y
they are from a domain of size k
that are correlated so i'll say what
exactly correlated means in the next
slide
and suppose they have one of these three
structures x causes y y causes x or
there are some underlying calls which
causes both
then
um then for any c there is an algorithm
that outputs the correct structure with
high probability
makes k to the c many observational
samples
and um mean of square root k and k to
the one minus c over two interventional
samples so what does this mean so for
example if c is two thirds then the
algorithm makes k to the two thirds many
observational and k to the two thirds
many interventional samples okay if
c becomes larger then you can actually
save on the number of interventional
samples but up to some point so you
of course need some number of
interventions but there is this tradeoff
between the number of samples you draw
from observations versus number of
samples you draw from from the
experiments okay
and the total number of distinct
interventions depends only on the
correlation strength and not on k in
particular
any questions about this statement
okay let me move one then um yeah here
let me just give a quick sketch of how
we do this so the notion of
coordination we use is that the
is that the total variation distance
between the joint distribution and the
product of the marginals is at least
epsilon so the way you should think of
this is basically as mutual information
some um statistical you know
log of new mutual information so where
if tv was kl this would be exactly
mutual information okay
and um
yeah so another way of writing this is
that if you look at the expectation over
y
of the
total variation distance between
the
conditional distribution of x condition
on one and the marginal distribution of
x
then this uh
i mean in expectation over y the
distance between the conditional and the
marginal is at least epsilon okay
and so what you can do is you can sample
a y from the
observational distribution
and roughly speaking with epsilon
probability
you will have that
or with like i say epsilon over two
probability you will have that this tb
distance is at least epsilon over 2 okay
and so if you make
order 1 over epsilon many samples of y
then for one of the y's this
total variation distance will be large
okay so we do something a bit more
refined in order to improve the sample
complex we use something called the 11th
work investment strategy to optimize the
number of samples but basically you can
think of it as choosing a random y from
the observational distribution
and
and um so that this holds true okay
and but what is the test so
if for example this was the case that y
causes x right then we would know that
the interventional distribution when you
intervene on y is the same as the
conditional distribution in other cases
the interventional distribution is the
same as the marginal distribution so
really what you need to do is you need a
tester
which distinguishes between the case
when the interventional distribution and
the marginal distribution are equal this
would be the case whenever uh this model
is not true
okay versus the case where the
interventional distribution and the
marginal this distribution is at least
epsilon
this would be the case when
this structure is true when y causes x
because again interventional
distribution
would be the same as in as the
conditional and we know that the
conditional and marginal
okay so you need a tester which
distinguishes which
solves what is called the closeness
testing problem so we have two
distributions we can get samples from
both we can get samples from the
interventional we can also get samples
from the the
observational and we want to distinguish
between these
and here
uh is where we use uh uh
a relatively recent work which
establishes a guarantee for closeness
testing when you have unequal number of
samples which is very mature and variant
with
so
yeah so the guarantee is that if you get
access to two distributions p and q
and you are trying to distinguish
between these two distributions so again
you you want to accept when p equals q
and reject when p and q are epsilon phi
then again there's this trade-off so you
take
m1 samples from p
and k over root m1 samples from q
but again so there's a
lower bound you need to take i mean you
cannot um take less than square root k
over epsilon square you need to take at
least so many but you can still uh uh
yeah i mean you can as you can see
there's this trade off so you can
i think again k to the two thirds is
basically where the two are equal
and um uh and between k to the two
thirds and k uh there is a tradeoff
between the object between the number of
samples to p and q
in our case uh like i showed in the
previous slide one of the distributions
p corresponds to the interventional one
to the observational and so this theorem
can be obtained
you can force it to either zero or one
right
uh but uh do you assume that the
intervention samples are sort of
available somewhere and there you're
picking from it so yeah so i assume
all right yeah so the question that i
understand is do i assume that the
interventional distribution is available
for sampling from right yeah yeah so um
yeah so in this analysis you actually
need to
you need to uh sample from this order
one over epsilon many interventional
distribution so
think of k as being large so for k equal
to two it's only zero and one that you
do interventions on but i mean think of
the setting where x and y take values
over a large number of variables you
need to do only a small number of
interventions and for those
interventions you need to take
the number of samples that i said in the
previous life
y has to be fixed for those one over f
right for each um so for each value of
little y
so you take one over epsilon values of
little y for each of those values you
draw so many samples
okay
um yeah so this trade-off between the
number of observation and international
distributions is actually tight so we
can show that um that information
theoretically this is optimal
uh and this closeness uh testing that i
described this is actually also a very
efficient algorithm which works well in
practice so chemist goliath is here in
the audience so he and others had a
paper recently where they gave a simpler
version of
this algorithm which works in practice
and has the same guarantees as in the
previous slide
okay um and a long-term goal i see is to
develop like a refined understanding
of the structure learning problem in
terms not just in terms of ci tests but
really in terms of understanding how
many i mean the sample complexities uh
for observational and interventional
distributions
uh in fact i mean you can ask these kind
of sample complexity questions in a
purely observational setting also
um
so for example in the recent work we
looked at learning trees via the chao nu
algorithm and um so we and askalakis and
pan we had concurrent papers where we
showed
the optimal number of samples you need
in order to
to learn a tree that describes the
observational distribution
okay okay so that concludes the
first part of my talk and now i'll move
on to a different topic which is again
kind of in the same flavor where we look
at
where we kind of differentiate between
number of samples to observational and
international distribution
so this is joint work with jaidev
disappeared in eurips a few years ago
so here the setting is a bit different
so in the earlier one we were looking at
two variables so here we are looking at
uh
at a large number of variables some of
them could be hidden
and we want to ask
about learning or testing hypotheses
about them so i
specify the problem in a
few minutes
um and yeah also what's different is
that the structure is fixed so here we
are not not
trying to learn the structure but we
assume that the structure is given to us
and then with that known information we
are trying to test or learn information
about the causal model
okay and the causal models will be
described by causal causal based
networks i mean if you're in the boot
camp you have surely heard of them and
so there are bayesian networks in a
usual sense where each variable where
each node is variable and also equipped
with a mechanism that generates the
value of that variable from values of
the parent variables okay
and we work in the semi-markovian
setting where
where the hidden variables don't have
parents
and uh each hidden variable has two
children
who are both visible okay so this is
uh yeah in some sense without loss of
generality
okay so the
so yeah so in our setting we get access
to an environment and like i said we
know the graph okay so so the graph is
known so we know that there are certain
number of hidden variables that we don't
have access to
and um and there are these visible
variables that we can sum okay
and what an algorithm we are looking at
algorithms which can either
observe the visible variables or
it can choose a subset of the visible
variables set them to
a particular assignment of its choice
and then sample from the interventional
distribution on the rest of the ones
okay so this is kind of in a very
idealistic setting so of course
i mean more refined versions of this
question would put restrictions on the
subsets that you can intervene on uh and
questions of that sort so this was kind
of the first attempt in this direction
so we i mean we looked at it in full
generality where the number of these
subsets are not constrained in any way
okay and uh yeah so you can sequentially
choose these subsets and then so for
each time you choose a subset you get a
distribution and you can draw samples
from that distribution okay and you can
choose how many samples
you uh generate from that distribution
this is like basically doing a
randomized control study where you make
an intervention and you choose the
number of subjects in that study
okay
so we looked at two problems uh testing
causal vision networks and learning them
so in the testing question
um
so we assume uh like i said so we assume
that we are we have access to an
environment x which can be described as
a causal bayesian network over a known
graph g okay
and we have we have to also assume some
sparsity conditions on the graph in
order to give
um
statistical guarantees so we assume that
the in degree of the of each node is
bounded and also that the c components
um
many of you must be familiar with them
so c components are bounded in size
and we get we can get iad samples from
observations or interventions on x and
we also have in our hand a hypothesis
causal bayesian network over g
and the question is to test identity
with respect to m okay so we are testing
so a scientist comes and says that m is
the true model and you have access to an
environment x and you are checking
whether x matches m or
not so the goal is to
um
reject so the goal is to accept when x
is equal to m reject if x is epsilon
part of them so i have to specify what
this fondness means for environments so
i'll get to that but roughly speaking it
means that no matter what intervention
you do
the inter
i mean x and m
so sorry so therefore if there is an
intervention that you can do which make
x and m uh be far which make the
resulting interventional distributions
be far okay
um
and um yeah so so the interesting part
is that again we get a guarantee in
terms of the number of samples so we we
take um
only logarithmic in n many uh
interventions
linear many samples per intervention and
polynomial time okay
um
and we get a similar identity for
learning so so here learning is that
you are
given access to an environment x and
again you know the graph so you know
that x is a causal bayesian network on
this graph you're trying to learn
uh the the parameters of this model
and um
so you can do interventions of your
choice like i said
and what it does is you it returns an
environment that is close to it so again
close will mean that no matter what
intervention you do the result of the
intervention on on x and the result of
the intervention on the on the learned
environment they are going to close
and again with a somewhat similar
requirement on number of samples and
iterations here i mean so when you say
sum is something is far from x i mean
you mean that there exists a set of
variables that are
any intervention that makes them for
right
yeah exactly thank you
yes there is a next night so again close
and far so say that two environments are
closed if for all uh subsets and all
assignments to go
that subset uh the resulting
interventional distributions are are
closed so there is no experiment that
that you could do that will reveal the
difference between these two
environments okay so it's again a very
strong requirement and one could loosen
it um for particular applications but we
were looking at the kind of the most
general version of the question yes
so just to clarify your m that you're
comparing to is a complete specification
of the functions right right in the in
the testing version of the question
m is
let's say a scientist comes up with a
full description of the whole model and
says that this is what describes the
system the environment and you are
checking whether x i mean whether your
observations and experiments
match with them or not yeah and in the
learning one there is no m which is uh
given uh you come out here so given x
you you learn uh a description of a
model which is close uh in the sense
m also includes hidden variables
m also includes a
well yeah so m basically in the second
one you're saying
yeah oh sorry in the first one right
yeah and that m is a full description so
it includes the hidden variables in it
yeah and actually these bounds can be
improved if the out degree is also
bounded
yeah and let me ignore the second one
okay so let me just tell you um roughly
what the argument looks like
and so there are two aspects of the
argument one which we call localization
and one approximate sub additivity so
localization means that we so ultimately
we want to make a claim about all
interventions right all
um uh so we want to say that over all
the interventions the uh the
intervention interventional
distributions are closed
right so there are three to the end many
so let's say we have binary variables so
then there are three to the end many
possible interventions so when you have
two to the n many subsets and for each
of those subsets you could make any
possible assignment um so that's three
to the end
but it turns out that i mean you only
need to
uh i mean this is not very hard to see
so you only need order n many
um many in interventions which specify
what the result i mean i mean so if you
know the distributions for order and
many of these interventions then you
would be able to also
so any any possible intervention could
be written as a function of these order
n many
interventions okay so maybe let me just
this is not hard i mean maybe it looks
more complicated than it is for the
fully observational case when there are
no hidden variables this would basically
amount to saying that for each variable
you look at the
uh the interventional distribution when
its parents are specified okay so they
are so if they're d parents then there
are two to the d times n many
interventional uh distribution so if you
if you know the interventional
distribution when for each node when its
parents are specified then you can
combine this information to get
the interventional distribution for any
any subset and any assignment okay
and you can run a similar argument when
you have bounded c components also so
this all the the order captures
constants associated with the degree and
the size of the c component
okay
and yeah one observation that we made is
that uh so even though you have so many
interventions you can actually observe
all of them in parallel so if you do
order login many random interventions to
the whole set then you can observe many
of these interventions in parallel
and
those random interventions allow you to
get samples for uh i mean at least one
sample of each of these interventional
distributions okay so that's one part
that you need only order login many
random interventions to get information
about these local um
about these local interventions
uh and the other part is so then what
the test does is basically it checks
each of these local these order n many
interventions
it checks
whether they are the same in x and m so
i'm talking about the testing problem so
there so you have m which is the
reference
causal model and x is the environment so
for each of these order n many uh local
interventions you check whether the
international distribution and x
and m are the same or not okay um and so
we have this approximate sub additivity
which says that if each of these
order and many local interventions are
um
yeah i mean so if you can approximate
each of these local interventions up in
the squared hellinger distance
then every intervention
would be learned up to um this order
epsilon squared l squared del injured so
square the linear distance
uh let me just write down so h square of
pq
is one minus
square root of p i equal
okay so this is let's say
a distribution on
on a set of size n
um
and um yeah so this actually
is kind of the most non-trivial part of
our work where we show that and this is
just a simple example for the front door
uh graph where you have
three variables so we need to kind of
solve a
program of this kind where you first
show so these are showing that the
local interventions are closed and this
is just
bounds that like the hellinger distance
is at least one and at most zero sorry
at least zero and at most one and from
that we need to argue that uh doing an
intervention on x and y and seeing z um
this is also um
right so so here i mean you're comparing
two causal models m and n so basically
this is saying that in m and n the local
interventions are closed and here you
try to show that the global
interventions are also closed
um
[Music]
uh available to solve this problem
so i'm not going into more detail uh but
yeah okay
all right so i see many open problems in
this direction so one is i mean doing
identity testing when you don't have
this guarantee that the causal graph is
the same so you have two environments
and you want to check whether
uh the two models i mean the two
environments where are they equal or not
means in the sense that
doing
uh arbitrary interventions whether does
that
will the interventional distribution
still be closed for the two environments
uh as i mentioned earlier here we don't
place any restrictions on the types of
interventions that the algorithm is
allowed but this is a very interesting
direction um trade-off between
observational and international samples
just like what we had in the first part
of the talk and one could also talk
about feedback when we don't have uh
directed graphs but you have feedback in
there
okay so with that i'll stop thank you
for your attention
[Applause]
we'll keep the questions again for the
panel afterwards so um uh we'll switch
over right now thank you very much ana
for very nice talk and perfect timing